this worker is checking the consistency
of a polypropylene sample every year
brazilian company braskem produces two
hundred and thirty four thousand tons of
the polymer at its two german plants
it's used in anything from car parts to
yogurt packaging the company's German
factories used to be owned by us giant
Dow Chemical Braskem acquired them in
2011 and has invested millions in their
operations since then a lot of money has
gone towards upping safety standards but
the workplace culture also seems to have
changed for the song equal twasn't i'd
say the culture is more open um Swift me
often they're more responsive to our
needs is comes walk they come here to
talk things over with us court soft I
rise at one's a hunt and they try to
keep things as personal as possible off
direct I even as a personage to Mohammed
braskem also decided to move its
European headquarters to Frankfurt the
workforce numbers 50 at present but the
company is hoping to expand its European
operations despite strong competition
from German chemical producers like BASF
Roskam considers the country a promising
place to do business the German market
is a very developed market technical
market and therefore it's an area we
want to participate in we see Germany as
one of the countries in the forefront of
the European progression and we noticed
that we want to make benefit benefit of
that thing and grow accordingly with the
jeweler market
Europe's economic woes haven't held back
brass combs expansion ambitions either
the company doesn't believe the euro
zone's sluggish economy will have a
major impact on their operations it
believes in the stability of the
chemical sector there's been a lot of
economic volatility here because of
what's happening in the economy here as
well as increase the data part it's a
very stable business environment very
predictable and the fastest growing in
Europe so we like being in Germany as
well as selling its German made products
in Europe Braskem also imports plastics
made at its plants in Brazil and the US
that's helped boost its European market
share to six percent